for me it's awareness and
and it's education and it's teaching um
you know i i've had some i've had a
as an awakening as such of my own prince
harry and meghan markle are honoring
british black history month by speaking
out about the issues facing minorities
in the united kingdom
and around the world black lives matters
is something that really resonates
with both of them i understand that this
is going to be
an area where we're going to see the
couple doing a lot more work and taking
a lot more interest
in a rare interview with the british
evening standard newspaper
the couple makes a list of next
generation trailblazers
recognized for challenging prejudice and
their positive contribution to british
society
and the 36 year old duke reveals he's
had an awakening to the issues facing
minorities
since first meeting his wife who is
biracial
i wasn't aware of so many of the issues
and so many problems with uh within the
uk but also globally as well i thought i
did but i didn't
the duke of sussex says that one of the
biggest problems is a lack of
representation
but he adds that placing blame doesn't
help fix the issue
it's not about pointing the finger it's
not about blame
and i'll be the first person to say that
this again isn't about
learning learning what our part is in
all this and how we can make it better
when you happen to look at some of the
names that um the people
from our list that we know some of the
people that they suggested
is really exciting so for example missan
had chosen
someone who created the black curriculum
and when you start just look at
history books and what we're taught to
see it through a different lens at least
see it through a diverse lens will help
shape
how children understand where they come
from and then to know better where
they're going
megan who notes that she and harry spoke
with black lives matter co-founder
alicia garza earlier this year
is in support of peaceful protests
supporting black equality
when there's just peaceful protest and
when there's the intention
of just wanting unity and wanting the
recognition
of equality then that is a beautiful
thing actually and so
you know while it has been challenging
for a lot of people certainly and having
to make this reckoning
of historical significance that has
gotten
people to the place that they are that's
uncomfortable for people
and we recognize that it's uncomfortable
for us historically members of the royal
family
don't speak out on topics that are
deemed to be political
but harry and megan stepped down as
senior members of the royal family in
late march
and harry acknowledges that the couple's
views quote
may seem controversial but he doesn't
seem to be afraid of speaking his mind
in fact harry added that they reached
out to britain's got talent judge ashley
banjo
who received complaints after his dance
troops black lives matter themed
performance earlier this month
as the world watched on another black
life gone
leaving what we thought we knew in
tatters
what we thought we knew some clearly
didn't
black lives matter we spoke to ashley
banjo
a few weeks ago and straight after the
the uh the britain's got talent um
situation and
you know that in itself i'm sure even
just me talking about it will become
controversial but the reality is that
you know he he and his and his team of
guys
put on the most amazing display in
addition to speaking with the evening
standard
the couple also wrote an essay for the
publication about the people they named
on their trailblazers list
quote for as long as structural racism
exists
there will be generations of young
people of color who do not start their
lives with the same equality of
opportunity as their white peers
and for as long as that continues
untapped potential will never get to be
realized
we cannot change history nor can we edit
our past
but we can define our future as one that
is inclusive
as one that is equal and one that is
[Music]
colorful
you